una vigilia de esperanza
[Música]
decenas de mujeres de organizaciones
feministas segregaron A última hora del
martes a las puertas de la Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos para
defender las libertades reproductivas de
las mujeres de la región unas protestas
enmarcadas en las audiencias de la corte
sobre el caso de Beatriz versus El
Salvador que empieza en este miércoles y
jueves Beatriz una joven de una zona
rural y empobrecida del Salvador tenía
Apenas 20 años cuando le diagnosticaron
lupus en 2011 tuvo un primer embarazo de
riesgo agravado por su enfermedad pero
su primer hijo logró sobrevivir tras más
de un mes internado Poco después volvió
a quedarse embarazada los doctores le
recomendaron no tener el niño que iban a
hacer con una malformación congénita sin
cráneo ni cerebro además la gestación
iba a afectar de manera severa su salud
tengo 22 años
y soy de Usulután le pido a al
presidente a Mauricio Funes que que me
ayude a que la sala acepte a interrumpir
el embarazo yo por todo esto que está
pasando Pues yo me siento mal pues
porque no quieren hacerlo pues
sabiendo que no no va a vivir el niño al
nacer pues sin embargo en un país donde
la vida se percibe desde la concepción y
el aborto está prohibido en cualquier
circunstancia Beatriz tuvo que seguir
adelante para evitar ser encarcelada el
bebé no superó el parto y ella cuya
salud quedó muy perjudicada tras el
embarazo terminó falleciendo en un
accidente de tráfico menor en América
Latina y el Caribe todavía hay cinco
países que prohíben la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo en todas las
causales en una región con muchas
beatrices ahora la Corte Interamericana
tienen sus manos evaluar el caso y si
procede obligar al Salvador a cambiar su
legislación una decisión que todavía
tendrá que esperar hasta finales de año